hello and welcome to this video playing
honey ducks and yep
good luck hisses huh no luck for you I
[Music]
tried something different just something
non theoretical hey he knows his stuff
he knows his stuff
he had the b5 set up this is the main
argument against White's move order my
water basically yeah basically delays
any c4 and black plane b5 is one of the
very few ideas that could potentially
cast doubt on that concept so let's see
what he does I'm playing very quickly
it's just a bluff I have no clue what's
quite not need I have no clue so okay
this is a way to stop to stop a six yeah
maybe you for now gets a bit more
interesting still still not nothing to
worry about for black
you know it's he's okay here that's no
doubt so I am wondering if if he's got
no and at the end there is at the end
there is a rook da it warm or what
exactly maybe I have to do this
like a tempo on the pond so that when
taking is not so convenient from there
is one thing definitely in my favor
I am Castle I'm a little bit quicker
here development wise
well it's not so easy here what what is
he doing here
not not certain what's good there is
always this idea with a knight discovery
okay so I could stick twice on the form
I mean this is a simple way of doing it
let's do it if he's not taking on c5 now
I probably have Queen to d6 keeping my
pawn and here my idea was to go Queen
deform keeping the momentum now he does
not have a move to cover before and a7
so trading is probably necessary and now
the issue is knight c6 I'm just
threatening knight c6 attacking a 7 and
B form this is what I meant with tempo
if he if he would have liked one more
move now yet if he would have castled
already and then he could possibly cover
one of those pawns but I don't see that
happening now not really 96 as a big a
big problem unless there is some defense
that I'm absolutely not understanding
I don't see how he covers the material
three is letting the clock run down to
low the issue is also simply that when I
win the a pawn the game is just over
yeah yeah him the thing is I got b3c for
coming yeah I'll just drop the one it
was not so strong take the file see for
next night on before it's nicely placed
ready okay now here what is he going to
do Ruby aid maybe go to a six now see
fauna there's no route B seven there is
no route B seven
okay it was it was already not possible
anymore to hold yeah again I was just
experimenting here in the opening so b5
is a valid line that is usually what the
strong guys play in this line it's to
show that C form was left out by wide
and should have been playing I played
this move might have already castles I
played c5 in this position however in a
game I think I only had it once maybe
twice not not often yeah but should be
seven is it still okay it's normal move
again from here on I'm just improvising
I have no idea I think I mean what I'm
doing
cannot be terrible but it's just like
normal normal stuff I'm a little bit in
doubt about Bishop a6 if that is so
great the engine likes it on that's it
doesn't disapprove yeah he says in the
chat he never managed to get out of the
opening alive against me yeah that's
true
I know it's a good
it didn't work out for him in the
openings okay I went in 4d takes Knight
takes yeah and here I think here is
probably a crucial moment yeah and I
think I'm right yeah after Knight f6
rookie Rookie five black is in trouble
it's just is this this precise move if I
don't do this I have to go 95 I have a
rookie five to attack the point if I do
something else he has route d8 I guess
well maybe just castling okay I was
thinking hoop d8 it turns out that this
is strong but okay this is tough to
figure out beforehand but the the key
about this is it's a temple move he has
to do something now he cannot just allow
me to take and he takes Knight X is
terrible I'm attacking the rook I have
this on the cards this is just not a
good position Bishop c6 yeah you cannot
take and yeah what what do you do I mean
the engine wants to do this but this
just concedes a pawn for nothing yeah he
tried rook c8 but then I think we get to
the game Queen takes 24 and terrible
yeah okay these I have to play other
when it's kind of natural my Queen d4 is
a temple move here here you get to those
kind of moves if you check what's loose
in the opponent's position so here the
pawns are loose the Queen cannot cover
both and I always have the knight coming
so let's say he goes here which would
cover both I have 95 the engine is on +5
that's that's crazy crazy yeah okay if a
seven falls it is terrible it is it is
terrible I'm still surprised +5 is kind
of drastic rook
ouch yeah
hey okay it's he's pretty pretty farm
and I mean the a pawn is on a five and
together with this damn and that is the
game which is also a bit of a disaster
you can also take a seven maybe it's
stronger but it doesn't make a huge
difference the position is just too bad
yeah okay gave me the Rue Cler but it
doesn't make a difference he says maybe
you should play Knight bd7
before Bishop b7 the knight bt7 is a
possibility I am not totally aware of
what the right move ores are I'm not
familiar with the system I played c5
them this is much I know I played c5 in
this position and it's what I had looked
at while ago not committing yet where
the pieces where the pieces should go
sometimes this might be an option for
example I'm not I'm not really sure it's
something that would need study but I'm
I'm improvising him okay guys I hope you
enjoyed the video thanks for watching